Previously known for starring in FX's hit
Atlanta, Zazie Beetz was as surprised as anyone
when she landed the role of super-lucky mutant
Domino in Deadpool 2.
USA Today called her a "captivating standout",
and Vanity Fair proclaimed her "the best thing"
about the R-rated sequel.
She slipped into the role like she was born
to play it, but getting to that point required
a lot of hard work.
Here's how Beetz got ripped for Deadpool 2.
"I am naturally not one to 'gym'."
A first time for everything
Beetz never had to work out for her roles
in 2017's Geostorm, or Atlanta, either.
But when she signed on to play Domino, she
knew it was going to require her to hit the
gym.
She told The Hollywood Reporter,
"In my routine day-to-day, I didn't really
work out that much.
So it was a huge transition emotionally and
physically.
[...] [I'd] never really brought myself that
far."
And she revealed it wasn't just physically
exhausting, telling Shadow and Act,
"The training ends up becoming this mental
and emotional experience as well."
Putting in the time
Beetz trained four hours a day for months,
to get into shape.
Before filming began, she told IBT,
"I'm going to be shooting guns, I fight and
a lot of that movement is full body and physical.
You're doing that for 12 hours a day and they
just want you to have the stamina."
Reflecting on the fatal on-set accident of
her stunt woman Joi Harris, Beetz also revealed
that leading man Ryan Reynolds helped her
stay focused, telling Entertainment Tonight,
"It's amazing kind of watching Ryan do his
thing.
He's genuinely, incredibly talented."
Trainer to the stars
You might not know Don Saladino by name, but
you've definitely seen his work.
Dubbed "The Superhero Trainer", Saladino's
client list includes Marvel stars Scarlett
Johansson and Sebastian Stan, and Wolverine's
Hugh Jackman.
He's also trained Ryan Reynolds and his wife
Blake Lively.
Saladino began training Reynolds for Deadpool
2 in February 2017, which was how he became
acquainted with Beetz, who admitted that she
loved working with Saladino, and the feeling
was very much mutual.
Becoming a superhero
After Deadpool 2 hit theaters, Saladino revealed
to PopSugar, that his first thought when training
Beetz was:
"We had to turn her into more of an ass kicker."
Saladino admitted that the style of training
he recommended for Beetz can intimidate female
clients, but he said,
"Picking up things like kettlebells and doing
things like squats and split squats — it's
the stuff that works the best.
It elevates the heart rate the most, and it's
not linear and so one-dimensional like how
most people train."
Eating a vegan diet
Because Beetz is vegan, her diet didn't really
change all that much during her Deadpool 2
training, but she told Shadow and Act,
"You have to change how you eat, and it also
takes away your energy.
[...] Doing that alongside shooting and prepping
and all that stuff, it's a lot of work, but
it was also really cool."
Crushing it
Playing Domino left its mark on Beetz, quite
literally.
She told USA Today that she has a scar on
her chest from a stray shell that hit her
during a shootout scene.
She also passed out from exhaustion, in her
leather bodysuit, in the middle of a fight
sequence.
But despite it all, she says it was absolutely
worth it.
She told RTE,
"We had been working so much, and I was thinking
hopefully it'll look good and I remember doing
the first take and then seeing the playback
and I was like, 'It's f-----g amazing!'"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus, check out this other cool stuff we know
you'll love too!